you were already live
hey
welcome everybody back to the break room
our special uh awkward starting holiday
party episode uh we're so thrilled to
have you here uh happy holidays to
everybody uh coming up on today's
episode of the break room which of
course is the show that gives you the
nerdy news you need to know but today on
this episode we're celebrating all of
our favorite things about the year 2022
in nerdy fandom this is not our last
episode of the Year we're doing a whole
week of shows next week but this is our
holiday party so actual new rock stars
holiday party today that's right uh
immediately after this show we'll be
getting down with all our co-workers
we're in the break room and everyone is
like get out we want to start the party
but we're like no we have a show to do
yeah that's right I've been partying
since 10 a.m
uh you can tell by that slicked back
hair this is a different breed of town
lady we got today uh with me in addition
to Tommy Victor we got Jessica Clemens
is here
[Music]
playing all those reindeer games we've
got
um
I was gonna say Charles Dickens uh
Brandon Barrick or yeah
yeah there it is I hate Christmas is the
Jacob I got a Christmas porno thing I
want to say but I don't know don't say
it Brandon's the Jacob these are sploo
oh we should go off later on we will uh
we'll promise them that that's their
gift my family's wife my mom's watching
okay Mom put the kids away okay
um and uh in honor of it being our
holiday party right we've partnered with
this awesome company iconic cocktails
there's a couple other products here
um the uh bitter orange tonic the
cranberry thyme uh mixer they make these
fancy cocktail mixers normally in our
mugs we've got water some people might
drink soda a g fuel here or there but
today we're making some fancy cocktails
uh some of us are drinking mocktails
some of us drinking cocktails Tommy
actually mixed these up earlier we have
some footage of uh Tommy making these
drinks uh that we might play in a moment
um but uh oh we so we we think I kind of
cocktail we'll talk more about them
later we also want to shout out
yesterday
um we had somebody send in Diana Santos
sitting in the Super Chat literally
right when we went off air so we didn't
get to thank her for that thank you
Diana yeah um but today we'll be doing
toasts with our iconic cocktails yeah
throughout the show
um we have some fun toast prepared also
if you have a toast if you do it if you
send it in a Super Chat we will
um we will read your toast maybe you
want to toast to your favorite fandom
this year maybe toast to the Batman
toast to Miss Marvel whatever you want
toasted just Sebastian Stan in general
for all you do all of his work uh
whatever you want or you want to toasty
yourself for a friend or or the break
room or whatever we'll read that out as
we go along
um we've already got a couple super
chats thank you uh Chris Christian
unpronounceable got in there uh Benjamin
wise thank you cheers
John back do we want to mention the
cocktails we made yes that we're
drinking so yeah yeah John can we play
that that fancy bartender footage of
Tommy wow look at this guy in his
natural habitat it's not on yet
let me just give you from my perspective
it was great to get behind the hardwood
again you know slinging a few drinks out
to my friends and fam now Tommy I happen
to know for a fact you have bartended
some holiday parties in your day I sure
have I I've bartended some holiday
parties you've attended yes uh you know
holiday party bartending is an art form
because everybody's there from the
entire company there are people who are
you know often tucked away in tiny
cubicles everyone's out in front and the
hierarchy much like The Rock has been
completely turned up by now uh well it's
like the DCU hierarchy it's like the
boss is usually snacker for whatever
reason the person the drunkest who has
the most uh most like Authority and
power because no one is going to tell
them they got too drunk and they get
vulnerable and then you also get the
wild cards the quiet people it's always
like the boss in like the newest intern
get the drunkest but it's like socially
acceptable yeah so insane and you figure
out like
are people just in a great mood or are
they drunk too early
yeah you're like did they drink before
in their first drink because like some
people they'll have one drink in the
back hey you uh I like to go pinch your
cheek and you're like okay you're
hammered all right uh we want to shout
out um Minix Monique's I don't know how
to pronounce that but thank you for the
Super Chat Nina you thank you happy
holidays here's to you in 2023
um okay so the format of today luckily
for us there's almost no news that we
haven't already talked about this week
so we can just have fun today and look
back on 2022 uh we are going to play a
little game of naughty or nice with all
of our favorite fandoms for the year
okay so we're gonna bring up a a fandom
a studio a streamer and one of us is
going to present kind of their Year and
that person is then gonna deliver they
were naughty or they were nice this year
and the rest of us will agree or
disagree okay
um so we'll start at the top start at
the top right Marvel the big dog in the
room the big dog in any IP room out of
the table if you will because the tribal
Chief when it comes to nerdy fandoms and
specific we're gonna break up Marvel's
year into films and Disney plus stuff
okay and so that'll be the streaming
series the special presentations so just
the films who's presenting on this
Brandon I'll present the movie okay the
movies we got to consider this year
Multiverse of Madness doctor strange and
Multiverse Madness Thor 11 Thunder and
of course wakanda forever yes ending in
rapping out phase four uh for me for
myself you know I think uh it was good I
think they did a great job with the
movies uh a lot of mixed opinions on the
movies but I had a lot of fun and I
thought they were all very different had
a good time cried a lot during black
panther yeah uh but I thought it was a
good into the a good 2022 for the Marvel
films I'm gonna go
it was a naughty year for Marvel movies
and I think it was a naughty year
because they had to unfortunately go up
against their Marvel series which I
think did a little bit better
we'll tease of the next category uh
Tommy yeah you know I will say I'm a
little biased because I was lucky enough
this year to because of travel see a lot
of these titles with my nephews and
niece so that made him a little more
enjoyable when you see him with a kid
they tend to you know see if they're a
different lens in a much more innocent
less jaded less online lens so I'm
saying it was nice the whole experience
camaraderie the uh trip to Target to buy
merchandise up yeah yeah I will say this
like I I thought about this a little bit
and my initial Instinct was that I was a
little underwhelmed by the movies this
year right I don't know that any of
these three movies or at least
um most of these three movies are not
gonna crack I think most people's top
five no right from Marvel movies maybe
wakanda forever might sneak in there for
some folks would be like my four because
black panther would be my three yeah two
yes but I don't it certainly I don't
think 11 Thunder's cracking most
people's top 10 maybe uh and Multiverse
Madness we'll see how that age is but
here's what I'll say and I think I'm
gonna end up going nice despite that
because a they had to this is like kind
of their first full year post pandemic
so it was kind of a comeback year
they're still kind of in the shadow
event game and then technically last
year had no way home which is one of the
five biggest movies of all time yeah
right it was like kind of this crowning
achievement they had to kind of fall in
the shadow of that this is like a a gap
year feels like next year they're
beginning some new stuff and this may be
the in between so with all those things
said yeah I'll go I'll go I'll go nice
okay now Jessica do you want to take the
Marvel series all the all the Marvel
stuff on Disney plus yeah
the Marvel series include Moon Knight
Miss Marvel She-Hulk werewolf By Night
the specials count uh I am grouped
guardians of galaxy holiday special
um I'm sure there's a little bit more
but we'll leave it at those ones for now
yeah and um I think they did a really
good job of with the series they got my
attention I think a thing we need to
remember is that Loki and Wanda division
were not this year right it keeps
feeling like it was but it wasn't but I
do think these series pulled me more
than the movies did and I think it's
only because like how you said the
movie's kind of underwhelmed me like as
a whole all of them I love to account
forever and I love shangshi but I'm also
like yeah usually in the phases I like
all the movies yeah so I think they and
yeah would it be covet or what have you
I think the series did a better job
getting a lot of our attention yeah well
also the Series this year launched new
characters we didn't get new characters
in the movies this year right like I
mean America Chavez and like little side
characters here and there but like no
this year or anything like that so like
we got She-Hulk we've got Miss Marvel we
got Moon Knight really all three of the
series gave us those and then I mean I'm
gonna go nice here
especially for those special presents
yes aren't we delighted that those exist
was it werewolf by night like
everybody's big surprise favorite thing
for the year definitely good on the
Series this year I love to Miss Marvel
it was very different a lot of fun and
yeah werewolf but I killed it I was
great it's also like the series I think
are moving closer to rated R stuff than
the show the movies are because the
movies are movies and the shows are
serious so they're getting us ready for
Deadpool didn't this feel like the year
where the series finally started to like
really Branch out She-Hulk is very
different from everything else that
Marvel does Moon Knight was pretty weird
and very different right like Tommy I'm
gonna do my Jim Henson puppetry skills
right now Brian Hudson you know if
you've been watching this show from the
beginning you know Henson and I don't
see eye to eye I'm gonna say green
[Music]
no Ashley no uh okay so here's what uh
almost all of it great a couple of
things uh I just personally didn't uh
necessarily love or connect with as much
I enjoyed it all though it's nice it's
fine I'm just you know we we do I do
think I am certainly biased of giving
Marvel the Marvel pass where it's like
if it's mediocre I usually put it bump
it up to good so I'll own that for
myself I also wonder Tommy one reason
you enjoyed the movie so much was you
had that theatrical experience yes you
had that with with your your family
members and like that old school thing
that we all fell in love with yeah
these we all watched on our laptop we're
on our by ourselves at home and I watch
whatever the crippling loneliness of my
manner uh by candlelight here's here's
what I say Marvel figure out a way to do
some big screen [ __ ] for some of these
yeah because like yeah you can still do
a premiere of like the first episode oh
my God and make it a bigger thing that's
more welcoming
the whole thing they did in Pakistan
because they don't have oh yeah plus
there where they played the first three
episodes of Miss Marvel theaters I bet
that would have been sick that would
have been sick and I would have done I
would have easily yeah so many things we
can go see obscure anime dubbed in you
know in English you know at Phantom
Events at any AMC yeah we can go to
church on Sundays in the movie theater
why can't we go to miss She-Hulk on
Wednesdays yeah and the special person
yeah the special presentation they do
bring to the big screen sometimes they
did with moon tonight you just had to
get tickets and it was it went out so
quick because it was 35 millimeter and
everyone was racing for those in L.A but
even the special presentations could
easily go to Cinemas for like a day yes
two days yeah do a little Glass Onion
okay A little split vote but it feels
mostly positive for both the markets
great job and in series now we're gonna
wade into their uh their friendly Rivals
DC we've split up DC into the Batman and
everything else okay so just the Batman
first Batman Tommy do you want to expand
Batman uh directed by Matt Reeves
starring Robert Pattinson and Zoe
Kravitz it's a nice for me guys that
whole thing was nice A detective story a
flawed hero learning that in the end
Vengeance can't be the only thing that
fuels you uh a surprisingly delightful
Colin Farrell not that I was surprised I
was delighted by Colin Farrell but all
that makeup and that voice and it was
was having the best and he loves it I
mean we we've covered on this show being
in a makeup chair for hours sucks being
in a makeup chair quite honestly for 20
minutes is not fun I've you know I mean
I've acted in things where they put a
wig on my head and it takes a little bit
of time to glue the wig on and I am like
a little bitty baby boy going
I can't imagine getting a whole like
body put on I mean you mentioned
comfortable let's not forget the PO
captain of the police who talk like this
[Music]
oh no because he's not the guy that gets
killed yeah he's also um
shout out to Paul Dano did he know did
he know Big Year for a day now Big Year
big year for new rock stars coverage and
if you meme to us you're dead to us and
we know where you live
if you meme doesn't tag is in it I'm
gonna find it
um real quick uh Joe 79m to alcohol the
cause of and solution to all of life's
problems
thank you yeah these super chats are
great guys we're not going unnoticed
that you have crawled out of your your
garbage dumps
yeah Paul little Santa everywhere
everything all at once
we will not mention that but that that's
a favorite movie for sure uh Mr Greg
Guzman cheers watching on my birthday
happy birthday
Sagittarius yeah that's right um oh get
out
Sagittarius his birthday's next week um
I mean or whatever sir uh no no it's
fine uh okay now that was the they're
not their only theatrical release but
the Batman and the Matt Reeves Universe
kind of exists off to the side the rest
of DC we had The Peacemaker series and
Black Adam were kind of the main
contributions and I guess we might talk
about Harley the Harley Quinn Animated
Series in a separate category but yeah
um thoughts on Peacemaker and Black Adam
I mean I'll do this I guess I don't know
you decide which goes where uh which
goes give me more series so we have
Peacemaker which is yes you know what
this feels like a very Peacemaker thing
but that mug would let me take my flag
out I'm going nice oh I'm going nice
Peacemaker was great I'm feeling
generous Peacemaker was awesome Black
Adam fine uh it's a bit of Pierce
Brosnan in Black Adam great the guy who
played Hawkman great green stall of them
yeah um it feels like a bit of an
incomplete year for them they had a
couple movies to get delayed next year
is going to be a big year right they
have four theatrical releases was two
three Squad not this year yeah Suicide
Squad was last year
um so maybe maybe this would be a more
interesting debate next year for DC okay
moving on Star Wars of course we did not
get any theatrical releases we will
never get a theatrical release from Star
Wars apparently uh but we did get three
Disney plus releases book of Boba Fett
Kenobi and Andor how do we think to help
with a Jedi also Tail's a Jedi sorry bad
batch trailer dropped I don't think
you're a short that was three minutes
long The andron Studio Ghibli uh grogu
shorts um Ghibli thank you
um so naughty or nice for Star Wars
Tommy you're our resident Star Wars
actually I'm doing a frantic flip-flop I
might be I might be running for office
I'm flip-flopping so much on this okay
book a Boba Fett naughty Kenobi nasty
yeah it's a nice way of saying very
naughty and or so nice I'll watch it
twice that's right that's right I'll go
green just because of Andor I don't care
what I'll say all of Star Wars happened
just to bring us to Android yeah I'll
walk down that road every day of the
week as a mild Star Wars fan I'm giving
it a red okay and when I say a mild Star
Wars fan I'm like I kind of want Star
Wars to get get the people that are like
me they're like kind of there yeah
yeah I think I I'm there too right this
felt like again I loved Andor that
almost but it's only a third it feels
like even Andor is a bit of a failure in
that it's such a great show and somehow
they didn't succeed in right marketing
that or having it connect with the
audience well I think the honest
marketing of it is tough to pull off
because they tried to get you excited
about following a character whose
Destiny we know right like we know where
he ends up which is similar to Kenobi I
hate to say and you know the only thing
that zagged off of that was Boba Fett
which was a character we thought was
dead but then learned and Mandalorian
was very much alive so sorry no no no
please I was gonna say it sucks because
they did do a lot of marketing for Andor
yeah it really does suck and it's
definitely like even after hearing
social media's cries of how good it was
it's still like it just is unfortunate I
wish that a lot of people will turn
their heads and go back and watch it yes
absolutely that's right um match 143
thank you another uh friend of the show
from Canada to the break room in 2023 to
the quiz Master to T Michael bechtold
and lastly to Kevin Costner I think we I
think oh yeah absolutely both team
Michael and the quiz Master are banned
from the building so oh don't hit it so
hard
oh Jessica's pinching me oh you did this
today in the meeting he comes in I bit
him okay let's talk about Amazon all
right they had a wild year uh the boys
rings of power the peripheral out of
range but I mean just because of the
boys baby also look at my filthy hours
of power is gorgeous
watch a little bit of perfume right I
did I loved it yeah with Chloe Grace
Moretz that's their newest show that's
on there I haven't watched out of range
yet which is on me no I've been seeing a
lot of the boys the boys was incredible
I've really been going up and I think
and when we talk about shows that are
afraid to take risk Kenobi uh and other
things like that the boys takes risks
kills people yeah stranger things uh
actually kills off its characters and
like has a good time and talk about talk
about adult themed yes
oh they get to the tip of the issue you
know what I'm saying it is the they were
they answered the question of what would
happen if Ant-Man just went in the butt
like they did it they did it for their
first episode yeah Amazon had an
interesting year it'll be interesting
um now how about another streamer I know
this one we've talked about a little bit
more recently because of all the kind of
drama behind the scenes HBO Max soon to
be called Max apparently yeah
um but and of course they're the home of
uh Warner Brothers stuff so they got all
the Harry Potter stuff they got all the
DC stuff they got some DC stuff that
will never see the light of day
including back like bad girl
um and they canceled uh um Green Lantern
series but the things they did release
this year House of the Dragon
okay White Lotus going on right now
finale coming up this weekend
um I really enjoyed Tokyo Vice I really
enjoyed our flag means yeah with the guy
from uh the Batman the the police
officer yes
um the previously mentioned Harley Quinn
animated series much beloved that's not
really an HBO Max thing that kind of
came over from another place but
um and the kind of Trifecta of weird
quasi-comedies Barry hacks and the
rehearsal rehearsal yeah Nathan fielders
the rehearsal tell me everything about
that show I didn't finish it because it
stressed me out it's stretched that show
is like a horror movie a reality show
and a comedy just like all wrapped it's
a psychological rollercoaster if if you
didn't watch the rehearsal when it came
out and you got the time over the
holidays give give that a shot I really
liked the HBO Max lineup this year yeah
go green oh sorry the dragon how's the
degrees
Olivia Cook but that's about it uh also
let's not forget HBO Max at a literature
called Minx that featured me for two
seconds
OMG Scotty saying cheers to all this
nerds having a daily escape with the
break room hey we love the Escape too
because we do not like doing our work
we'd rather be hanging out there
this is me saying a toast to my fellow
trash bags here's to an amazing 2023.
hey you know what we often uh denigrate
you we uh desiccate you we defenestrate
you but today the defenestration we've
never thrown any of the break room
Chatters through a window but today we
celebrate you here's to the transplant
before we move on and Jessica's going to
present the next uh one which is really
good one we want to call out so the
drinks we're having uh we have two
signature cocktails we've been talking
about all week long and actually the
recipes are in the description with the
um a cranberry thyme mixer for my
country there's some accent
look at that serious face
at the camera oh my gosh get them out of
there beautiful uh but yeah you can get
these mixers yourself at
iconiccocktails.com yeah a new use code
new rock stars get 20 off yeah you know
I'd be normally working a lot faster
than that for all of you that are going
to throw some hate in there but we were
doing it for the camera okay he couldn't
afford to spill a drop
oh
you see Lady
Jessica slammed that drink at 9am that
was great uh yeah again the downhill
ever since we're making the I'm sipping
on the quantum Manhattan yes I am as
well shockingly yeah cheers to us and
take on the Manhattan uh made with their
cranberry time uh oh I'm not I'm sorry
I'm drinking the alcohol no and Tommy's
actually Tommy and some other focus on
the panel are drinking there nowhere to
go this is Tommy Mickey now it's a mock
oh look at that poor it's got no alcohol
in it yeah but it does have their tasty
bitter orange tonic and there ain't
nothing to mock about it it's flipping
delish delish oh one for one for her one
for me Daddy once I made sure my lady
was taken care of now that's what they
call in the business a sip and smile
that's right hire them for commercial
guess what I've been in this town for 15
years I know how to sell products
speaking of wish we want to thank our
sponsors at Flags today Flags you can
fly them anywhere damn he sold me
for our next one and it's on the Netflix
y'all yes and we know this Netflix
brought brought a few out this year
stranger things Umbrella Academy
Wednesday Sandman Cabinet of Curiosities
Resident Evil and inventing Anna and
Dahmer whoa you know what I'm going
crazy stranger things umbrella there's
Academy on Wednesday made so much money
here's the deal I'm I'm saying a naughty
I'm naughty I'm not on Netflix get over
your binge mode okay
I agree also I will give you a green
just for British Bake Off thank you oh
you're going back and forth
season two the binge thing is the only
thing I can hold above other people's
haircuts I hate it I started midnight
end at 9 00 A.M
real quick I I included in that list uh
though it's not usually in the new
Rockstar's wheelhouse inventing Anna
just because I wanted to hear Brandon's
impression yes why are you releasing
your episodes every week it's so basic
are you angry that you're so fat because
you sit and watch all your episodes at
one time it's the stupid Banks it's the
banks I would release it everywhere
let me cancel my credit card two people
like how you did with the Great British
baking show yeah I'm gonna do green for
everything red for Resident Evil it did
not it did not perform well okay all
right I'll take the other let me think
please Top Gun green flags all around
every wave your green flags we'll go for
launch other movies we had Jurassic
world Dominion didn't see it minions
green Sonic too didn't see it everything
everywhere all at once green Knives Out
Glass Onion green that was great check
it out I only gave two of those Reds and
it was Jurassic world and minions
they should make a dress Jurassic world
Dominion oh oh
I love Sonic but everything everywhere
all at once I'm putting all my money
I think it's got a real shot at it and
Michelle you over best dad oh Stephanie
Stephanie sue for supporting uh Jamie
Lee Curtis now now real quick another
another company that's gonna have a
bigger year next year than this year
because they'll have more releases and
then even in more the following year as
well uh the spumcy the Sony Pictures
Universal Marvel characters they just
had one movie this year
and it was morbin time okay as the mug
says Ah now you're nice yeah you want to
know why I'm naughty say whatever
I had a great time with my friends as
mandated by Sony Pictures I had a great
time with my friends
I did enjoy I had three ipas during the
movie and then I had four gin and tonics
at the bar afterwards yes I give it a
seven drinks out of seven thank you to
the Sony publicity team for uh letting
us all go together and we got special
things we have to wear yeah we got to
wear fangs they set up a little red card
and real quick we don't We're Not Gonna
maybe go through all of these but you
know we didn't think about Apple TV had
Severance Hulu had that great Predator
movie and then they've got it in the
bear which we also make jokes about all
the time I love it uh yes chefs
Corners Corners Hulu fans they have the
great FX shows like Atlanta and the old
man and a lot of kids have like always
sunny yeah still killing it and how
about The Simpsons plugging along yes 49
years after a debuted
Simpsons and Jessica
true it's it's not older than me
I watched the first episode that's right
real quick let's shout out Matt Farrow
thank you for the Super Chat uh cheers
from the iconic team yes Matt the CEO
one of the co-founders of iconic we're
loving it I'm a huge fan Matt I'll be a
customer for life that vanilla you put
in coffee my God yeah it makes for a
great gift we were just talking about it
before about how like this is a really
nice gift it's a fancier thing that you
can send a friend it makes more sense in
the mail than food or something like
that it's a really nice thing
um Boogie's World saying happy holidays
Breakers thank you Boogie uh Freddy
fairy saying I'd like to toast to my
dead parents thanks to them I'm one step
closer to being Batman hey hey when you
go I don't know with your parents take
the front entrance Freddy Ferry coming
in from New Zealand yeah yeah okay it's
tomorrow we're Freddie fan Freddy I
don't know if that's serious or fake or
half true but either way I'm gonna raise
a glass yeah and see your parents
because they either raised a hilarious
son or uh or or a very sad situation uh
Uncle Dev TV was choosing uh Jessica's
green dress he loves it he says he's on
one knee he said marry me but he spelled
it m-e-r-r-y so that's very close
Christmas if it was an a I would have
done it yeah
green dress love from a dumpster fire
big head gang yeah gang gang do you have
a big head gangs here somewhere also
film just saying cheers to the break
room I don't have a problem and you're
not a neighboring Miss I'll show you
I've had enough oh wow that's pretty
funny film juice I still don't think we
should have read it
uh Perry Clemens no relationship happy
happy Friday happy holidays love y'all
hey love back to you oh and cook two is
wondering how we felt about the Roku
Channel coming in hot with their Weird
Al Yankovic story Thomas I mean that was
debut Brandon didn't like it all right
here's the deal it was a baller move by
Roku it was very smart right they should
have put it out commercial free put it
out at the beginning
you know what is not enough songs not
enough songs in the weirdo that's why
you didn't like it and we know what is
free on Roku Bill Burrs immoral Compass
featuring myself as an Alex Jones person
who gets murdered
okay that's not worth it for a little
bit I'm gonna plug all my personal
problems let's go also if you just want
to keep up with Tommy content you got to
be on like five different subscription
Services trust me it's expensive for me
to watch myself and it's my favorite
thing to do uh uh the um the MJ 2997 one
of our good friends from your Gucci to
from your moochie to your Gucci I toast
you all for getting some Christmas
the other thing that rhymes with moose
yeah yeah
Christmas yeah yeah okay
Christmas Stanley church
my wife wants Stanley Jersey for
Christmas I think next year we're gonna
sell Tucci uh
like an elf on a shelf
there is a trend on Tick Tock right now
and on Twitter that people are like my
wife thinks Stanley Tucci's attractive
can you guys please tell me I'm not I'm
not wrong and thinking he's not and I
was like no everyone thinks Stanley
Tucci's attractive it's also yeah he has
good bone structure all sorts of energy
with Tucci yeah he's got a very
attractive he's got a bde for sure
what does bde stand for Tommy uh Brian
Dawkins the former safety for the
Philadelphia Eagles and foreign
at any point
um but we are uh fittingly for our
friends at iconic cocktails who have uh
helped us make these delicious drinks
and hopefully some of you out there are
enjoying your Quantum Manhattan or
you're nowhere to go there's the the
promo code by the way uh again makes a
great gift ship that to some family and
friends and enjoy a nice cocktail it's a
great way for them to up their Cocktail
game we really we we're friends of the
the folks at iconic cocktails they've
been really good to us uh we love
supporting them we love their products
um uh but we were gonna give some toast
some toast to specific things yeah yeah
yeah uh we're celebrating the holidays
today as you can tell we're drinking
some iconic Cocktails so we get some
toasts to our favorite of the fandoms
this year you know you saw a little red
five green flag and we have some special
guests around the office who might pop
in to give their toast as well I could
do mine first oh please that's okay uh
if I may have your attention please a
toast to a great show called Andor a
star war that we've never seen before
did Ramiro was crass Cyril Khan was an
ass Iman mothma let her daughter be sold
in the store and to Lutheran I must make
a toast for his ship was simply the most
he ran a sweet shop thought all the imps
should be shot and he wanted to make
Cassian a ghost Here's to You Android
way to go apologies
who do we have popping in here oh oh no
oh no oh no the holiday spirit with a
little uh mistletoe Holly who knows just
kind of I think it's poison oak
you're out of it is made of a Christmas
tree
wow how many I I don't like I don't I
agree with the killing and skinning of
trees
this is what you do as a vegetarian I'm
not a vegetarian okay sorry do you have
a toast you'd like to give Anna I have a
toast now everyone might have seen that
the Mario movie's coming out I've been
doing the coverage of the trailers so my
toast is in honor of Mario it's short
it's sweet and it goes a little
something like this may all of our 2000
that's not it I should have brought my
notes it's the shortest toast in the
entire world may our
2023s be filled with pipe rides mushroom
heads and uh mustaches on our tanookies
oh my gosh
I don't have a drink I gotta go get a
drink
my goodness definitely check out all of
Anna's great uh Mario movie coverage
it's on the channel right now it's
people been loving it wait do you hear
those
oh my goodness hi I have a little song
for you guys
I wrote a little Christmas song for
stranger things the TV series okay
vacnet killed at e in the upside down
Mike wheeler was also in a movie with a
clown
through Max's headphones so let's put up
the Christmas lights and tell Will to
come home no stranger things stranger
things Jonathan is snow what a stoned
Robin's gay and Steve has hair and
Hopper Drinks Alone stranger things
stranger things look out Lucas run
Dustin has a trash can lid and Nancy has
a gun
that was great
[Applause]
my toast
here's to the Thunder God named Thor you
got your ass kicked by Gore you brought
back Jane Foster and soon after we lost
her but your penis went down to the
floor
all right you have a new rival named
Zeus ready to let the war dogs lose in
omnipotent City those manners are shitty
but for real Thor your dick is a spruce
I will say this this has never happened
before I'm a little horrified
who knew for it confirmed Brian Dawkins
energy that's right
shut it down anyone else
oh he's coming back
real quick we've had some fun ones in
the chat Jamir green sending in his
Super Chat Marvel needs more darker
darker themed animated shows like Modoc
yeah also go Ravens and then ah boo
why'd we read that it's unfriendly
things about the bells
oh uh match 143 coming back in from
Canada Anna to Anna yes
um uh trash bag saying how do you guys
feel about the content released on
thrust TV well it's crazy thrust had
some really really huge shows what were
some of the bigger shows on thrust ah
there was wait a second that's not my
mouth uh which was a baking show
ironically there was holy smokes I can't
fit that whole thing inside me which was
a three-part documentary on cheese
makers and then there was
whoa whoa where do you think you're
going with that ham hock which was a
story about a pig farmer Wire magazine
said all the footage on thrust this year
was
the t's done
magazines gotta get a better editorial
stats
shout out shout out to trash bag for
bringing back a better inside joke than
anybody actually who makes this show uh
Matt Farrow cheers to the best Channel
ever Merry Xmas y'all uh
you could create uh uh here oh can you
read that one here's to alcohol which
often makes one see double and feel
single oh I love you all happy let's
hope let's hope you get to sleep triple
I was about to say sometimes at these
parties you know what I'm saying Jessica
you got a friend coming tonight okay oh
boy wow and then uh uh um t sterling
t-shirt TC Sterling TC Sterling coming
in with a beautiful emoji and uh you're
amazing thank you thank you TC Sterling
back at you babe yes absolutely uh you
know as much as uh this isn't a
Thanksgiving episode but certainly we
all have a lot to be thankful for this
year here we launched a show in May uh
and you all the the little weirdo trash
bag community that has grown around the
show has been awesome uh you guys uh
have been super supportive and fun and
often funnier than us uh we appreciate
you for watching for being a part of it
uh for helping us grow this weirdo
little family we have but we did new
rock stars and specifically at the break
room
um now Tommy yes uh we might have some
more toasts but uh and I don't mean to
cut anybody off if they had a good time
no mine mine is my toast was simply uh a
uh takedown of the chat
they've been so generous that I okay
I'll try here's a toast to the chat that
often sleeps sleeps covered in chat oh
they don't wear nice clothes they live
in dispose
and that's all I have to say about that
oh beautiful beautiful right after I
said all that sweet stuff it comes in he
comes in hard on them but uh tell me I
believe there's a a secret yeah guys
there's a little secret Santa and what
happened is I want to do a secret Santa
with everyone and then I forgot to tell
everyone so I was I had to give everyone
presents but it's no secret I also uh
you know it's Christmas time I don't
have a ton of money so what I did is I
went into my personal comic book
collection oh and I got comic books for
each of you that I thought would be
something you would like oh okay I'm
gonna hand them out John there's even
one for you too you piece of crap Mommy
will show off the person that we got
here I don't think we're allowed to show
that on the internet what you bought me
on air look at our Instagram uh but
check the gram Brandon oh thank you look
at these gift boxes yes thank you CVS
for allowing me to purchase these all
right so if you want to go one at a time
I'll explain them to everyone these are
from the bechtold archives oh okay and I
guess these technically there's nothing
secret about this Santa it's you know
it's me I'm just a Tommy Santa John this
is for you so Zach okay here I'll pop
this one open uh a lovely uh Santa Claus
box there what I gave you I'll let you
guys open this is a first this is a
number one first edition of The
Flintstones DC Comic now Zach is a new
father yeah uh with a lovely family Fred
Flintstone a new father uh in this comic
now this is when they did the
Hanna-Barbera DC reboots where they made
a Madman style Flintstones and that is
the first issue they ever made uh Fred
flinster looking very John Hamish on
this cover thank you Tommy I'm actually
really interested to read this I thought
you'd enjoy it it reminded me of you who
wants to go next I can go next okay
these are all once again from the
Bechtel comic archives
love Santa that's a little aggressive
Santa oh
that may look like any other X-Men is no
uh that is no accident this comic is the
first appearance of when jubilation
that's beautiful the first time Julie
ever appeared in a comic book and it is
now yours
man what is that uh that is 244 yeah
I will I will admit that one I did not
have in my collection my friend Brett
Carreras who is a very good friend runs
Richmond Comic-Con uh pulled it from his
uh comic books so thank you Brett uh for
making a Christmas uh wish come true uh
for me that I could then give this
Jessica's tearing into our past Jessica
let's see who works on that thank you
GSU Eagle thank you guys for the great
deal it shows over the year it's been
fun uh shout out to Duffy Duffer the
rougher Duffer brother we all messed up
oh the rubber Duffer brother was uh
someone who they didn't send in the
Super Chat
they just said something really kind
that was like you know thank you to the
break room crew for getting me through
this year and and we just want to say
the same thing to you guys like you know
doing this show has been some of the
most fun we have at new rockstars is
because of all of you
um and we're really appreciative and
John of course does not speak for the
on-air Talent that's right that's right
everyone's garbage yeah okay Jessica's
got her gift
Jessica yours is a little bit of a
squint if you can see it it's a very old
what if comic book it is what if Uncle
Ben had lived and here's why I gave it
to you you are our spider-verse expert
and that is a multiversal tale from the
what if uh original line I believe it's
maybe even the first what if comic book
ever is what if Spider-Man joined the
Fantastic Four yeah that I do not have
but this might be the second or third
what if ever made so it's pretty old
it's a nice piece of comic book history
now John this one I gave to you because
this is the one that I would most want
and John and I are very off camera
similar simpatico uh this is what we're
gonna be allowed to show this on the air
yes I have I have a few of these that I
got from Brett actually a few years ago
with their prized possessions of mine uh
everyone I taped these boxes not
efficiently John yours is a Jimmy Olsen
Superboy featuring Don Rickles
yes at one point DC Comics said Don
Rickles has to join the Universe
[Applause]
I believe you will get done in the book
drawing drawing foreign but I don't
think I've ever taken that one out of
the package okay what are you you baked
potatoes
gross I hope he rose uh so anyway uh and
daschal uh is on her is he coming
tonight he will be here okay uh just
I'll open dashels so you guys can see
what I got him uh the actual is a huge
Star Trek fan yeah and I'm not I promise
I'm not Shilling Brett carreras's uh but
I didn't get this from Richmond
Comic-Con this is a Star Trek Dash was a
new Star Trek guy Star Trek Green
Lantern crossover that he commissioned
although the book was already made he
commissioned this variant cover from you
can only get at the Richmond Comic-Con
very nice yeah now let's be honest I'm a
psychopath I probably have doubles of
all of these so it's like I'm really
good I don't want to put me out pedestal
here whoa uh uh Freddie fairy our friend
from New Zealand coming back uh daughter
not son short for Winifred it's true but
the best comedy comes from sadness oh
okay uh
here's to the guaranteed uh chuckle
every day from the break room crew and
fellowship cheers to you and this is not
our last show of the year although it
may seem like it will be here next week
but this was when everyone was going to
be in the office this is when our actual
holiday party
next January it's my birthday so next
week uh we're still doing shows next
week this week we uh today we were kind
of looking back at 2022 next week we're
looking forward to 2012 that's right
that's right we've got a lot of fun
stuff planned for next week as well
before I take off and let you guys
finish your show I just want to say
thank you to some people that are not on
the show very often but helped us get
the show off the ground uh Philip Molina
Patty uh Dodson Samantha Samantha all of
our great moderators in the chat
um anyone else in forgetting I apologize
and then for our frequent guest Eric
our work friends that we sometimes drawn
Eric Whitney Mt and Hannah bless you all
hopefully Mt will be yeah and then we
gotta we got a couple more uh driving
around super chats we want to get to uh
Christian unpronounceable coming back
here's a toast to Jubilee absolutely
Here's to You Chris always Jubilee the
trilogy being announced soon uh Cynthia
or Cynthia
uh happy holidays guys love you all and
I enjoy getting to nerd out with you all
ah well we love it thank you
um Joshua Hartke we're also we're about
to have another special guest
um uh Joshua Brandon can you see that
one uh Joshua Harkey saying you're all
rock stars I want Tommy's jacket and I
will tell him for it wait wait wait and
I definitely love how you always think
it's a positive way to present even
mediocre shows I don't know uh what
mediocre shows it could possibly be
happy he's in the break rooms mediocre
you know what it's a bell curve there's
going to be some hot stuff there's going
to be some cold stuff you know what I
mean easy says his toast wasn't red I
don't know
oh I apologize easy what was your toast
um
uh uh line of demise Cobra Kai
okay is our does our special guest need
a moment okay what you eating here we go
I love him so much
would you like to give a toast to
anything out there this year I want to
give a toast to Mr Chadwick Boseman who
um I wish she was there for uh wakanda
forever obviously you couldn't be
because he's now gone but like my
goodness um a black panther 2 with uh
Chadwick Boseman would have been amazing
and incredible but that's not why we're
toasting we're toasting to his life in
this amazing accomplishments at the MCU
and um too because like we would not
have the amazing nation of wakanda and
like all the
um tremendous things
um about like especially the tremendous
lessons that he taught shuri about like
forgiveness and like you know being able
to work with the uh people of talocon
like we just we love you chachala so uh
but here's to you yeah yeah yeah
uh thank you Mt Joshua Joshua Harkey
yeah I think Brandon just mentioned
you're all rock stars I want Tommy's
jacket Tommy does have a jet matching
pants you may not be able to tell from
from the
cheers to the Scarlet Witch and Soldier
Boy the two pick best characters who
deserve an epic crossover that would be
soldier boy who is that so this way
this was a great year for the scar witch
I'm glad to see her so powered up uh and
definitely not dead she's coming back
and she's coming for Revenge I love evil
Scarlet Witch don't let her be good let
her be evil let her be let her be bad
come on
come on thank you all for watching I
think
um this this cocktail has been delicious
it's hitting me just right uh in the
sense that if this show goes 10 more
minutes I'm really gonna say some stuff
that's right oh boy these mocktails have
me feeling like I pretended to be drunk
because I say this and I'm like wait you
haven't had any alcohol yet today but
what we do have oh this is a special
little song
this is a brand new Banger uh made
specifically for the break room we
actually stole it from Barry manilow's
house oh yeah from his estate yeah he's
dead uh he's dead to me oh okay is he
hanging out with uh dick cavette
bless you did Kevin come on the show
come on the show now come on the show
phony horses in the chat and let's get
out of here ready let's sing it one two
three oh
It's gotta leave here we got back in
music
[Music]
oh there's no place like break room for
the holidays
no matter how much you dislike and or if
you want to be happy with
you with all the holidays you can't beat
our Pandora
I met a man who lived in Canada and he
was waiting for the chance to come on
the break room and be free come on the
break room if you coward was the emo
sits prayed in Brandon's hair dancing
Tom says smash or pass from the
headlines to predictions
oh there's no place like break room for
the holidays
[Music]
watch it already
if you want to be happy
[Applause]
for the holidays
get back in the garbage thank you
when you fight for the sunshine of a
friendly day
[Music]